Every knitter needs to understand
basic sweater styles.
How do you choose what style
of sweater you want to knit?
There are so many sources of inspiration.
You can comb your library of knitting
patterns,
maybe find a photo on the web or
in a store,
or maybe you've seen someone in a crowd
wearing a sweater that you love.
Now, whether you chart your own sweaters,
use a knitwear design software program,
or you follow knitting patterns word
for word, it's valuable to understand
the various basic sweater shapes.
If you're short on time or you're
an absolutely new knitter,
you probably want to choose an easier
style with the least amount
of shaping in the body and sleeves.
Are you looking for a more tailored look?
That means more shaping,
but the results are well worth the effort.
Let's use Penelope, the paper doll,
to examine some basic sweater styles.
By far, the easiest and quickest
style is the drop shoulder sweater.
For a basic sweater, the only
shaping would be in the neckline.
This style is great for oversized,
comfy, casual sweaters for adults.
It's also for babies and kids.
Really quick knitting.
Now, the drawback of this style is there's
a lot of bulk at the underarm,
and it's not particularly
flattering for adult women.
To eliminate the bulk and still have
a fast and easy shape to knit,
there is the modified drop shoulder style.
It's also called a square arm hole.
You bind off a few stitches
at the underarm, you change the sleeve
shaping a little bit,
and again, you have a very casual style,
and the knitting is still quick and easy.
You'll often see men's
sweaters knit in this style.
It gives lots of room in the arm hole.
The modified drop shoulder also
accommodates a large
range of shoulder widths.
So if you're knitting for someone and you
don't have all of their specific
measurements, this style is perfect.
It isn't critical where
the shoulder seam falls.
The most tailored style
is the set-in sleeve.
This is the classic shape for sweaters.
The shoulder seam should be precisely
placed according to the
wearer's shoulder width.
The curved underarm also adds
to the fit of this style.
The set-in sleeve cap eliminates extra
bulk on the top of the sleeve
and offers a more fitted appearance.
Now, this style has the most shaping when
knitting,
and sadly, many knitters avoid set
in sleeves,
but the extra time to shape the arm hole
in the sleeve cap is well worth
the professional appearance
and the appealing silhouette
of the finished garment.
Here's another easy to knit sweater shape.
It's the raglin' sleeve.
Now, the straight line decolour creases
when knitting this,
they're really easy to knit and they offer
you an opportunity to add stitch detail
along the seam for a really
personalized sweater.
Many knitters will knit ragged
and sleeve sweaters from the up, down.
Now, this adds to the speed of knitting
by joining the pieces as you knit,
and it also offers a break
from our usual hem up construction.
Like drop shoulder styles,
raglins can accommodate a wide variety
of shoulder widths, making them
versatile for babies, kids, and adults.
Train yourself to recognize the basic
sweater shapes when looking at ready-made
garments or knitting patterns.
This will help you determine if
the pattern is right for your next project
based on your skills and the time you want
to devote to the finishing the sweater.
Now, machine knitters often complain
that there aren't updated machine
knitting patterns available.
Here's my challenge to you.
First, learn to translate hand
knitting patterns to machine knitting.
Second, chart your own patterns
from styles that you've seen.
And finally, if you use knitting software,
practice it and master it.
Arm with this knowledge and some practice,
soon you'll find that the sky's the limit,
and you'll be knitting all of those
beautiful designs that are
rolling around in your head.
Knit it now has more resources about
knitwear design, along
with many other topics.
Please consider becoming a member,
and let us help you become
a better machine knitter.
Happy knitting.